hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's time once again for our weekly
catch-up we go through all the map
updates for fortnight Battle Royale
and as the week's fly by we add our own
theories and build the story line ready
for the end of season event so sit back
relax prepare yourself for terrible dad
jokes and if you haven't subdue ready
think about joining our dysfunctional
family today it's completely free it's
free every free it's always free Adam
idiot we've approached week two already
I can't decide if that feels really
quick or it feels like the mechs have
been here forever how do you feel about
those big buggers by the way okay the
biggest news of the week is the changing
of tilted from neo tilted to tilted town
by flying through the dome we are
transported back in time to the Old West
where pickaxes seemingly hadn't been
invented and building was too difficult
to even bother well those are the rules
anyway you can't harvest and you can't
build there I'm sure this place is
stressing out pro players but for
something completely different is pretty
damn awesome how did you do on your
first landing there I banged out 219
kills who the hell am I kidding this is
what really happened absolutely but the
real thing I want to talk about here is
the storyline connotations the
importance of what's happening so here's
what we already know obviously the time
continuum has been disrupted creating
this new temporal event sequence
resulting in this alternate reality I
don't have a clue what I just said I
literally took it straight from back to
the future
Great Scott in laymen terms after the
objet at loot lake it caused reality to
split dragging future and past events
into the same version of the world we
can already break these down in week one
we saw risky reels and the gulf cut from
lazy links return but here's where it
gets a little bit freaky things aren't
coming back the way they were before
they are altered such as the chair house
in West world it's been replaced by a
television filled house we even saw
elements of the corrupted zones pop up
but in really strange places like this
little building and did you stop and
look at the stood Depot on day one
color order has changed we may not be in
the same world right now there will be
two sides to this story what happens
with the meteor which we'll get to very
soon but right now it's all about what
humanity will do with that are power and
the first thing was tilted town a few
days before this happened
tilted had a flux capacitor added aimed
right towards the broken rift taking
energy away and siphoning it into this
machine but here take a closer look at
the machine it has a fraction of the orb
a rich yard to power it also it really
looks like the vault key from
Borderlands and in that one once it was
activated it linked together all the
planets in the galaxy and the vaults
they had there but that's a story for
another time I do get sidetracked easy
so my but I apologize but stick with
this so the island scientists somehow
recreated that beam of light we've seen
so many times to crack open the dome and
bridge time and dragos back in time to
the wild wild west
Will Smith would be proud yeah so what
do you think will happen next
I think we'll see this flux capacitor
moved around the island each week
changing different spots probably lazy
links next week because I want to have a
golf challenge in one of my community
streams please but other than that what
are your hopes many people want to see
moisty return I personally would like
the prison back go on have a guess what
we'll return next week oh and remember
motel is there any chance that could
reappear somewhere on the map I hope so
let's bring this back down to earth with
a very important update to HUD watch
nothing nothing at all this week this
will go down in history as the slowest
direction of all time that was a bad
choice of words see you next week here's
something I noticed on my travels is
probably nothing but I want to say it
all the same have you noticed that the
tool boxes are somehow searchable now I
found this one above pleasant Park but
there's nothing inside but I thought it
was worth mentioning moving on the story
of the stone family has been an
interesting one at the end of last
season the family was complete we had
mom dad son and dog but then they all
vanished never to be found again or have
they I've been searching twitter for
answers and in some distressing news the
story of the stone family may have been
solved it's a tearjerker a crashed RV
has been found with the remains of the
family with only the dog surviving
anyway don't worry if you took that one
seriously that has been there for so
long it's been here for weeks
so we can safely say that that is not
the demise of the family there's more
chance that they are in the loot lake
explosion oh hang on
oh no rock the Dwayne Johnson Sharon
Stone kid rock pebbles the rock viola
of course I'm only jesting there what do
you think will happen will they return
to us I have a suspicion if wailing
woods comes back we'll see part three in
their story almost as touching as hug
watch now still not change how often do
you visit lucky landing well did you
notice the change this week the
overlooking tower has been partially
replaced with a rickety old Shack just
like the old days
can anyone remember the pile of vehicles
that used to be down this area before
route 66 dropped in those are damn good
memories here's a few things I missed in
last week's video they may not be
important but wow they deserve a mention
Thanks to everyone who told me there is
indeed a moai back in the game already
over bipolar peak gotta love that chair
hat but the full-on weirdest thing in
the first two weeks of season 10 sorry
season cross sorry season X is the shack
between snobby and tilted have you seen
this thing everything is upside down in
the hood what could it mean is this what
the stranger things people meant when
they said the upside down I've got a
joke for all people why is this Shack
Lionel Richie's favorite place because
he loves dancing on the ceiling hello
sorry I'm so sorry I don't know why I do
these things like usual a big THANK YOU
to those who use code Adam aru I'm not
allowed to tell you how much the code
makes but I can say that it's never made
as much as it has this season and that's
why it's all going back to you guys in
giveaways all season long we've had 18
winners so far and all of that is
possible because of these guys on screen
that used code Adam aru so thank you so
much you make this community great you
really do if you buy something new in
the item shop using code ed Amaro please
send me a DM and I'll get you in a video
thanks very much right let's talk about
that visitor
have you been paying attention to the
changes at dusty devil deep depot Depot
it could reveal the storyline and what
we can expect after only one day dusty
began to be ransacked shelving and other
units thrown outside to make room for a
makeshift lab but then something arrived
a piece of the meteor I know that dusty
divot had the meteor chunks inside but
by then the meteor had landed in that
scenario but in this one it's still
floating in the sky so how did that
thing get down here someone must have
brought it down in a super subtle change
first a watch post was added to the roof
of dusty you know a simple chair and
telescope but a day later it upgraded to
a satellite dish inside the room updated
again becoming more workable with more
tech around so what story do you build
from this some people are suggesting
that this is the government preparing
hastily for the meteor to arrive but I
think the real culprit here is the
visitor let's break it down originally
he arrived crushing into the divot
escaping his pod and running over to the
villains lair to build a rocket by the
way the villains lair is a complete dump
this season he then shot skyward had a
few troubles and was gone never seen
again
but now we know that isn't true in the
current world we've seen his pot and
once again it's already open but this
time before the meteor hit the ground so
that means he's already out there and
you know what let's let's add a new
element to this video series
let's cosplay
[Music]
season X begins but somehow the meteor
doesn't hit the island the visitor wakes
sensing danger probably like this or
maybe like this now he definitely wakes
up like a badass and leaves the meteor
instantly seeing the final building in
dusty as the first place outside of the
blast radius he begins to set up a base
of operations taking with him a piece of
the meteor to power his plan
coincidentally he makes himself at home
you know frolicking on the bed waiting
to use the loo which is weird because he
lives alone at present this is now in
stage two of his plan okay but there's
where I'm completely stuck what the heck
could his plan be escape annihilation or
could he be the one who has changed
Tilted come on point me in the right
direction I really need help if you have
any ideas and like me to cosplay it up
like this please get in touch on Twitter
I'm Adam granade over there so we're
trying to put this into a story but you
see there's one character or one set of
characters that I think are integral to
this story which we haven't even looked
at yet these little military police
things like space cops
what could they represent maybe they're
hunting him down and that's why he's so
quick to want to leave again that would
fit in quite well but I don't have the
slightest idea but I do love trying to
put all these things together with each
map update I hope you'll like it too
because I really do like these meetups
each week
anyway pencil me in for seven days from
now and we'll see how things have moved
forward I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been a bloody pleasure like
always thanks for your time I much
appreciate it a season
[Music]